recently jeff bezos announced that he
would be going to space with his brother
on july 20th using new shepard this
would not only make him the first
billionaire to go to space
but more importantly the first owner to
use his own rocket
it should also be mentioned that this
will be new shepard's first crude flight
into space
considering this jeff's space flight is
not a joyride by any means
no it's a statement piece specifically
designed to destroy skeptics
for years people have talked down on
blue origin discounting their
achievements as mere copies
and laughing at their slow pace but as
jeff bezos steps down from amazon to
fully focus on blue origin
the trajectory of blue origin is about
to radically change
so here's the story of blue origin and
how jeff bezos will ravage the haters
before we jump into the video let's
address the elephant in the room
which is of course spacex there's no
question that spacex
is way ahead of blue origin and that's
unlikely to change
but that's okay blue origin does not
need to be the best space company out
there
to be a leader in the industry this
video
is more about how blue origin will
disprove the notion that the company
is a joke and how blue origin will go to
be the number two space company
in the world with that being said let's
take a look at the roots of blue origin
blue origin was originally founded on
september 8 2000
which is ironically almost two years
before spacex
at the time jeff bezos was actually in a
pretty rough position financially
as this was during the midst of the
dotcom crash amazon stock had already
crumbled from 113 dollars
to just 45 dollars but the fall was far
from over
by september of 2001 amazon stock would
fall to under six dollars per share
which wiped out 95 of jeff's wealth
fortunately
amazon stock has since recovered to well
over three thousand dollars per share
today but that rise was by no means
guaranteed
at the time clearly jeff ended up
starting blue origin
during uncertain times but something
that was absolutely certain though
was his love for space you see jeff had
been dreaming of pushing forward the
space industry since his high school
years
in fact jeff wrapped up his 1982 high
school valedictorian speech with quote
space the final frontier meet me there
given this passion jeff would invest the
money he did have into rocket engine
development
no one really knows the specifics as to
what they were working on and the blue
origin was extremely secretive with
their plans
but we did get a couple of hints here
and there in 2003 for instance
blue origin would start to buy large
portions of land in texas
presumably for testing purposes and in
jeff bezos would actually have a lunch
meeting with elon musk
to discuss their space companies and the
future of the industry
according to elon musk jeff was
constantly proposing ideas that spacex
had already tried
and discarded apparently he advised jeff
to trash these ideas
but jeff would go ahead and try them
anyway to find out for himself
jeff wasn't in any rush to build up the
company as fast as possible
by this point amazon stock had recovered
quite a bit
so he was in no rush to win commercial
contracts or launch a rocket
he strongly believed that slow and
steady was a key to victory
that's how he built up amazon and that's
how he was going to build up blue origin
in fact their mission statement
proclaims we are not in a race
we will go about this step by step
because it is an illusion that skipping
steps gets us there faster
slower smooth and smooth is fast
evidently jeff did not care about speed
but
what he did care about was
experimentation and innovation
one of his earliest ideas was to
vertically land new shepard
which dates back to 2005. a common
misconception
is that vertically landing rockets
boosters was elon's idea and that jeff
copied it
but in reality this idea is now original
to either of these guys
the idea to vertically land rockets is a
classic within the space industry
and dates back to the 1930s for instance
in the 1959 movie the sky calls we can
see a rocket landing that's basically
identical to that
of falcon 9 and new shepard so this is
not a new idea by any means
spacex and blue origin simply made this
fan fiction a reality
anyway moving forward jeff would do an
interview in 2008
where he revealed his plans for new
shepherd his goal was to conduct an
unquote launch in 2011
and recruit launch in 2012. clearly
these dates did not
pan out but that's basically the case
with every space plan
in april of 2015 blue origin would
finally conduct their first uncrew test
flight of the new shepard
unfortunately the booster would crash
during the landing however the capsule
would land safely
though it took forever for blue origin
to conduct their first launch
there is definitely some truth to jeff's
philosophy of slow and steady wins the
race
since that first launch blue origin has
conducted 14 launches of the new
shepherd
all of which were 100 successful and
this
is why i'm so confident that jeff will
indeed fly to space
this summer the july 20th date may not
hold up
because of logistical technical and or
weather related delays
but these factors shouldn't push back to
flight more than a couple of days
or weeks in the worst case completing
this flight will bring blue origin
more interest than ever before as we
discussed at the beginning
jeff would be the first owner to ride in
his own rocket and the fact that he's
willing to be part of the first crew
speaks volumes about how much he trusts
her product with the virgin galactic for
instance
richard branson has been teasing her
right on spaceship 2 for years
richard however was never willing to be
the first to test his planes
and throughout their history a pilot was
even killed during a test flight
so let's not forget that rockets and
space are extremely dangerous
and things have gone wrong as a result
jeff completing a flight on new shepherd
would give potential customers a level
of confidence
that is unparalleled within the industry
now
i know a lot of you guys will point to
falcone's reliability and that
is absolutely true but new shepard and
falcon 9
aren't really comparable falcon 9 is an
orbital rocket that costs tens of
millions per seat
new shepard is a suborbital rocket the
ticket cost of about 250 000
per seat i know that their first new
shepard ticket was sold for 28 million
dollars
but that was more of a fundraising
effort and the buyer paid a massive
premium to be the first civilian to
bring new shepherd
with that being said blue origin will
dominate the sub-1 million
space tourism industry over the next
decade which will be the vast majority
of the space tourism market
itself blue origin's only competitor
within this market
is a virgin galactic who doesn't have
nearly as strong of a track record
so jeff's space flight will solidify the
company's future in space tourism
and be the first step in disproving the
haters new shepard is just a suborbital
rocket though
to solidify their position as a space
later they also need to have a strong
orbital rocket
and that's where new glen comes into
play blue origin has been developing new
glen since 2012
and they currently plan to launch a
behemoth in the fourth quarter of 2022
now that date may not come true but
euglen development truly is in the home
stretch
by far the hardest part of developing a
rocket is their rocket engines
new glenn is supposed to use a be4
engine but new glenn
is not the only rocket using this engine
united launch lines
actually contracted blue origin to build
the be4 engines for the upcoming vulcan
centaur rocket
which is still expected to launch at the
end of this year
this means that the engines are almost
ready to go assuming that the vulcan
centaur launches at the end of this year
or early 2022 new clan can't be that far
behind
even if they don't hit the q4 2022 date
and 2024 would be highly likely launch
dates let's just say that we see new
glendae flight by 2025.
with the payload capacity of 45 metric
tons new glenn will be the second
largest fully reusable rocket
ever built only beaten out by starship
if new glenn beat starship to a
successful orbital flight
new glenn would temporarily be the
largest fully reusable rocket
this of course comes along with the
plethora of commercial contracts
and interest blue origin has already
attracted several commercial partners
and i'm sure they'll make quite a bit of
money as a launch provider
but what's really interesting with new
glenn though is lunar missions
since the very beginning returning to
the moon has been one of jeff bezos
primary intentions they've got the blue
moon and the human landing system
and though blue origin didn't win the
artemis contract they aren't giving up
on the moon by
any means if we say that blue origin
completes a crude space flight using new
claim by 2030
it's quite likely that blue origin will
get humans to the moon in the early to
mid 2030s
again this will be nearly a decade after
spacex
but that doesn't take away from the fact
that blue origin could very well reach
the moon before
any other country this means that blue
origin will be one of three
organizations that have the ability to
put humans on the moon
and i'm confident that blue origin will
be the one to leverage this ability
here's the thing spacex's main goal is
to make humans a multi-planetary species
by settling mars
so the moon will not be their primary
focus
meanwhile nasa's main focus is research
and development
so they don't really care about the moon
beyond building a research base
and conducting in-depth research this
gives blue origin the perfect
opportunity to be the ones that
commercialize the moon
and neurospace throughout the 2030s this
includes space manufacturing
space energy production space tourism
space hotels and so on and so forth
jeff's primary thesis has always been we
have to go to space
to save earth though jeff thinks it's
important to research other planets like
mars
he thinks the primary purpose of space
is to serve people on earth
whether that be reducing pollution on
earth by manufacturing in space
or providing people on earth with an
exotic travel destination
considering this over the long term i
believe that spacex will be the
colonists
government space agencies will be the
scientists and blue origin
will be the commercialists and this rule
starts as soon as jeff bezos
successfully completes a space flight
destroying the haters and opening up the
gates for commercialization
do you guys think that blue origin is
overly scoffed at
comment that down below also drop a like
if you would like to see blue origin
disprove the skeptics and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest you future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm re i'll see you guys on the next one